John Legend reacts to Kim Kardashian's
Paris robbery lettin people know that
we're real people too you know naturally
Kim is still shaken up after being
robbed at gunpoint
earlier this month her pal Chrissy
Teigan husband spoke out about the scary
incident on sway Sirius XM show Friday
with a message for everyone using social
media I think we have to be careful
about snapping and things like that
because people know exactly where you
are when you're snapping I don't think
you should go through life thinking that
that very worst thing can happen all the
time because that's what that was like a
extremely rare kind of thing that isn't
likely to happen very often in anyone's
life it's like a one-in-a-billion
situation you just can't go through life
in fear all the time and we try
announcement
Chrissy broke her silence early on
defending the reality star against
trolls joking about Kim's
life-threatening experience she tweeted
something just isn't funny followed by
this tweet that read Fame is interesting
celebs are supposed to love you guys
while also knowing you make a meme of
our dead bodies to get retweets
you